c'est un problème important pour lille 1
mais nous la résoudrons alors françois
que décidez-vous j'hésite facteur c'est
vraiment une chose importante
moi je trouve que tu devrais accepter
parce que président de la fête annuelle
de l'île aux enfants d'autres a fait
grandement sérieux tant pour sûr et
c'est même un titre très honorifique au
facteur le savez très bien que les
honneurs ne m'intéresse pas tellement
non et puis je voudrais pas gêner la
candidature de monsieur les snobs qui a
tellement envie d'être président de
l'afep
c'est bien vrai ça fait pas un candidat
mais si elle pour en avoir envie vous
savez il en a envie
j'ai entendu dire qu'il sait déjà
comment des nouveaux chapeaux et un
nouveau costume tellement initiaux entre
l'ue a décidé mon nom je pars je préfère
renoncer enfin si jamais j'étais élu la
peine de monsieur snob ne gâcherait tout
mes joueurs autant raison parce qu'au
fond il a un peu agaçant comme ça mais
il est très sérieux et très honnête
est-ce qu'il a des chances d'être élu ou
c'est le candidat le mieux placé vous
savez un tenait un manhwa zèle
mademoiselle verado à peu de choses ob
c'est une gracieuse la gugga serait tout
la fête aux coups reçus
mais il ya aussi le gardien du port et
millefeuille negro goma et ben je suis
sûr qu'il est se présente pour avoir la
plus grosse teuf vigato que les vous
avez toujours le mot pour rire dit d'or
vous trouvez que c'est bien de dire du
mal de tout le monde là c'est pas si
vous le prenez comme ça j'arrête de vous
lire la liste des candidats de toute
façon moi je vote pour monsieur 10 9
mars mais je crois que je lui donnerai
aussi ma voix rien que pour le spectacle
attention attention voilà casimir qui
arrive au je crois qu'il vaut mieux
changer de sujet 1
si jamais il apprend par monsieur disney
est candidat pour la présidence
il va absolument vouloir lui aussi être
président qu'est ce que vous disiez au
sujet d'un monsieur du snop
je crois que tu as pas les transferts je
comprendrai jamais comment plaisir peut
avoir leur you seen alors qu'il n'y en a
pas qu'est ce qui se passe afin
d'évoquer mais non casimir on est en
train d'inventer un nouveau jeu pour les
enfants
bon mais à propos de monsieur du snob
oui bonjour julie est lui quasi legend
quasi nerfs je m'excuse pendant que j'y
pense tu n'as pas une lettre à me donner
pour poster non non facteur mais vous
parliez de moisi dont casimir qui
arrivent a dit manger bon gloubiboulga
hier soir vous me prenez pour un
imbécile je sens que je vais me mettre
en colère
casimir et tu te calmes et même pas de
métro cola ok j'ai mis on ne fait pas ça
un bon mais alors au à propos de
monsieur dix neuf blessés c'est sans
importance
je sens que ma colère moa non non non
mon vieux bon bon bon bah écoute casimir
tu as gagné
moi je gagne toujours bon alors à propos
de monsieur du ce nombre est bien il se
présente aux élections pour être élu
président de la fête annuelle de l'île
aux enfants au suffrage universel au nom
alsa françois qu'est-ce que ça y va
comment appelez-vous ça le suffrage
universel pour et bien ça veut dire que
tous les habitants de l'île ont le droit
de voter
c'est à dire que tout le monde dans
l'île peut voter
exactement on dit les grands les bons
les méchants les gros comme le facteur
les métros les gens riches les pauvres
que ce soit des gens importants ou pas
dans le suffrage universel
tout le monde a le droit de voter et le
vote de chaque personne a la même
importance
par exemple tient quasiment en france eh
ben c'est comme ça qu'on élit le
président de la république et les
députés
bon mais fait les enfants aussi en
france pour avoir le droit de voter il
faut au moins avoir 18 ans
il faut bien comprendre ce que c'est la
politique bon mais ici sur l'île aux
enfants pour l'élection de la fête par
l'île aux enfants tous les enfants
doivent voter
bon d'accord excuse moi je vais vérifier
quelque chose
non non j'ai bien peur que casimir ne
commence déjà sa campagne électorale
facteur oui casimir vous m'aimez bien
avant pour sûr bon temps parce que vous
me préférait tu le sais bien voyons que
q quand tu danses pendant ta chanson ah
oui comme ça
oui comme ça là mon vieux
je t'adore merci-facteur julie oui dis
moi je dis tu me préfère comme ça comme
ça ou alors comme ça de n'importe quelle
façon
de toute façon tu es mon préféré alors
je t'aime de toutes les façons merci les
enfants
ecoutez-la écouter les enfants
est-ce que vous menez bien ouais bon
merci merci bien
diderot casimir ça s'est bien passé
ah oui je suis un petit peu essoufflé
mais ça s'est très bien passé
elle a tant mieux dis moi oui est ce que
je peux te poser une question avec les
éléments qu'est ce que c'est que la le
ballottage à le ballottage est bien aux
10 à l'ours qu'aucun des candidats n'a
obtenu la majorité absolue
c'est à dire plus de la moitié des votes
on doit alors voter une deuxième fois tu
veux bien me répéter ça je te le répète
tmi on dit cela
lors ce qu'aucun des candidats n'a
obtenu la majorité absolue c'est à dire
plus de la moitié des votes
on doit alors voter une deuxième fois
bon d'accord d'accord
pardon écoutez moi
écoutez moi tout ce modèle je suis
candidat à l'élection de la fête du
présidentmd l'île aux enfants
quoi tu veux vraiment te présenter à
l'élection ouais j'ai décidé de mettre
ce ballot de monsieur du snob en
ballottage
kazim